Sí muy muy buenas gracias por la
invitación Mire yo creo que el viaje
tiene varios aspectos Uno de ellos es
transmitir la idea de que se lensky
puede viajar esto de por sí ya es
importante porque lo que está
transmitiendo es la idea de que el
presidente se encuentra en una situación
suficientemente segura para realizar un
viaje transatlántico y eso es indicativo
entonces de que la capacidad de la
federación rusa de alterar el
comportamiento de zelenski Es realmente
negativa o neutral y lo segundo tiene
que ver con el hecho de que no es
necesario viajar a Washington para
confirmar algún grado de apoyo como
usted lo decía en su presentación esto
tiene altos grados de simbolismo
simbolismo de que la relación es una
relación cordial simbolismo también de
que se leensky probablemente va a ser
recibido con una ovación por parte del
Congreso y al mismo tiempo Esto va a ser
transmitido por todo el mundo lo que
incide directamente en una opinión
pública rusa que ya se encuentra en
declive y que ya presentado muchas
críticas respecto a cómo se está
desarrollando la guerra Bueno entonces
Cuál es la diferencia y la importancia
de hacer un desplazamiento físico porque
hasta el momento se le es que digamos
que sea desenvuelto muy bien
comunicándose virtualmente No solo con
Estados Unidos sino con el resto del
mundo bueno es importante constatar de
que no todo el mundo es invitado por
Washington eso ya tiene un cierto
estándar de relevancia de carácter
internacional yo creo que esto también
transmite la idea sobre todo para los
europeos de que se lensky es alguien que
va a ser recibido por el presidente de
los Estados Unidos por la principal
potencia a nivel mundial y eso
eventualmente puede consolidar la
alineación que Europa tiene respecto de
este tema no hay que olvidar de que
Europa ha sido relativamente
desestabilizada respecto de el apoyo a
Ucrania sobre todo pensando en el
invierno europeo en las altas cuentas de
Electricidad y en ciertos movimientos de
política interna pensando sobre todo en
el gobierno italiano Yo creo que el
hecho de viajar a Estados Unidos de
recibido por biden de permitirle hablar
en el congreso transmite la idea de que
Estados Unidos está detrás de ese lensky
y por lo tanto debe alinear a todo el
resto de los países